do you want to see what weaponized
ignorant looks like this is a term that
applies to the current American
president very precisely and so much
that it's sometimes scary and I'm gonna
set this up for you today so Trump puts
new tariffs on China again starting
today Trump says if China retaliates
with tariffs because of our tariffs then
he will do even more tariffs which is
exactly why trade wars are not fun and
not easy to win
so early this morning Trump puts out
tweets that once again put in doubt
whether he is good at English and it
definitely rules out that he knows
anything about economics this is a to
tweet comment that's one of trumps
dumbest if you look at the content of it
okay Trump says there th e IR th e IR
there is no reason for the US consumer
to pay the tariffs which take effect on
China today this has been proven
recently when only four points were paid
by the u.s. twenty-one points by China
because China subsidizes product to such
a large degree also the tariffs can be
completely avoided if you buy B Y but
from a non-tariff country or you buy the
product inside the USA the best idea
that's zero tariffs many tariff
companies will be leaving China for
Vietnam and other such countries in Asia
that's why China wants to make a deal so
badly so the grammar and spelling
mistakes are at this point these are
things we learned when we were eight
years old I remember the conversation in
third grade where we talked about there
there there and two two and bye-bye and
how all of this works and Trump is
publicly commenting on trade policy with
embarrassingly bad English and it's a
continued embarrassment around the world
but then let's really dig into the
content because that's what matters most
Trump doesn't understand that American
consumers pay the tariffs on China one
way or the other
Trump's economic adviser Larry Kudlow a
far-right winger when on Fox News and
admitted that economists and businesses
are correct that we pay Trump's tariffs
Trump genuinely thinks that China pays
the tariffs so he believes he's
punishing them with
the tariffs take some item aluminum for
example that China sells to us American
companies build stuff with aluminum when
they buy Chinese aluminum they start to
pay a tariff on it on that aluminum to
the United States government right the
American company pays the tariff to the
American government on the Chinese
aluminum the Chinese company still just
gets paid for the aluminum since the
American company had to pay a tariff on
the aluminum they will add the cost of
that tariff to the finished product
whether it's a car or a house or other
products that are made from aluminum and
so the American consumer in the end pays
the tariff the idea is as Trump suggests
if the tariffs are high enough it will
make American companies and American
consumers get their aluminum from
American companies instead but in
reality it's just not that simple very
often the products that are tariffed
aren't available as easily in the United
States or the cost difference is still
so great that it still is cheaper to pay
the tariff on the foreign stuff and keep
buying the foreign stuff which is just a
net negative for American consumers and
American corporations this is a red
alert because Donald Trump thinks that
tariffs are a good idea because he
doesn't know how they actually work he
is destroying the economy with these
tariffs that have no off-ramp they're
only escalating not de-escalating and he
thinks that they work in a completely
different way than they actually do he
has to be stopped he has to be removed
and the easiest and most direct path is
just voting him out in November of 2020